und diese sendung bei bild live beginnt
mit der wichtigsten nachricht zu ihren
alltag und die steckt ihr drin in diesem
papier ja denn es ist freedom day man
könnte sagen endlich ist es soweit
zwanzigster märz das ist das
entscheidende datum da sollen
wesentliche corona maßnahmen ja das was
sie hier sehen das ist die vorlage für
den neuen corona gipfel am mittwoch
beschlussvorlage heißt das und das ist
so wichtig weil da ja immer drin steht
kommen neue maßnahmen oder fallen die
endlich das fordern wir bei bild seit so
langer zeit und so massiv und jetzt
kommt das ding auf dem tisch gestern
abend 23 30 fertig geworden und da steht
jetzt endlich so ein satz drin auf den
wir so lange warten der expertenrat der
bundesregierung steht hier drin geht in
seiner aktuellen stellungnahme davon aus
dass der anstieg der zahlen in den
nächsten wochen zu einem ende zu einem
ende kommen wird also ganz wichtige
feststellung endlich von karl lauterbach
von dem ministerpräsidenten von der
ganzen bundesregierung und das führt
jetzt zur ankündigung von öffnungs
schritten vorsichtig vorsichtig schritt
für schritt aber immerhin es ist von
drei schritten die rede und es beginnt
erstmal mit dem privaten na das wird
wirklich zeit man darf sich dann im
ersten schritt ab sofort wieder mit mehr
menschen zu hause treffen na endlich und
dann aber ganz wichtig für alle es geht
um die ja um den besuch von gastronomie
zum beispiel in einem zweiten schritt
nämlich würde ab dem vierten märz also
das ist das datum dass sie sich schon
mal merken sollten ab dem vierten märz
der zugang zur gastronomie für geimpfte
genesene und alle anderen ermöglicht
also das heißt zweig ist dann geschichte
soll geschichte sein wenn das
tatsächlich beschlossen wird am mittwoch
ab dem vierten märz 20 22 und dann ganz
wichtig der dritte schritt auf den wir
so lange warten das ist nämlich die
insgesamte öffnung sozusagen der freedom
day den wir so lange schon erlebt haben
in anderen ländern in schweden in
holland in dänemark auch auf mallorca
mittlerweile also ab dem 20 märz dann in
gut einem monat soll es soweit sein das
ist das eigene datum ab dem 20 märz 2022
entfallen alle
tiefgreifenderen schutzmaßnahmen ganz
wichtig die masken pflicht die soll noch
weiter
aktuell bleiben in deutschland aber alle
tiefgreifenderen schutzmaßnahmen so ist
es hier in diesem etwas komplizierten
papier verfasst die sollen dann fallen
am zwanzigsten märz was sagen sie dazu
zu spät wir fragen nach mit kira ortmann
heute in der strahlenden sonne von
berlin freedom day erst am 20 märz
bin ich eine totale befürworterin dafür
weil ich denke wir sollten jetzt mal an
die wirtschaft denken und an die kinder
einer schule das eben regelmäßig zur
schule gehen können es wird zeit dass
mal wieder so der alltag kommt und man
ich immer im hinterkopf haben muss sich
testen zu lassen und welche ausweise
apps parat zu haben also ich finde die
maßnahmen jetzt nicht so schlimm ich bin
dreimal gilt also mich stolz wieso nicht
und ich wäre glaube ich trotzdem masken
tragen einfach weil ich gemerkt habe
dass ich weniger krank werde naja ich
finde das sehr schwierig weil es wurde
ja schon oft gedacht dass es jetzt
besser würden vorbei ist und bisher hat
sich nicht bestätigt wenn sie das kommt
jetzt auch richtig zum richtigen
zeitpunkt das hätte schon früher so sein
sollen von kunde ja schon natürlich ist
das gut wenn das für uns alle wieder ein
bisschen freier wird aber ich bin schon
der meinung dass man nicht ganz auf die
massen verzichten sollte wenn alle
geimpft wären dann wäre schon viel
früher kommen vorfreude natürlich freuen
uns darauf und wir würden uns wünschen
dass das eigentlich funktioniert weil es
wurde ja immer nach hinten verschoben
und nach unten
also wer kann haben viele trauen dem
braten noch nicht so ganz damit haben
sie erstaunlicherweise weil es am
mittwoch im pkw ist da kann man das was
hier drin steht auch so beschlossen
werden und wir sehen auch einige hängen
richtig in ihrer maske und so könnte man
fast den eindruck haben auch claus
strunz
also ja ich freue mich wirklich über den
freedom day usw aber das gleichzeitig
schon wieder drin steht in dem papier
ist das hier vorgestellt habt und das
also sozusagen der gedanke der politik
schon wieder ist also wir schaffen jetzt
zwar zweig ab aber diese verfluchten
dinger sollen die leute bitte weiter
tragen das regt mich jetzt schon wieder
auf aber einmal ganz kurz zurück es ist
natürlich gut dass sie es jetzt endlich
verstand namen der politik dass sie
endlich verstanden haben dass man nicht
ein ganzes land ewig gefangen halten
kann und dass sie verstanden haben dass
man mit dauernder angst und dauernden
apokalypse nachrichten nicht jahrelang
reagieren kann also dass das gute in
diesem moment heute dass der freedom day
kommt der schlechte ist das bleibt noch
eine weile aber gut ich bin vielleicht
sogar geschenkt dann bleibt es halt was
mich mehr bewegt ist wenn jetzt doch
fest steht dass man die maßnahmen als
überwunden ansehen kann dass man sie
weglassen kann dass man sozusagen den
menschen wieder ihre freiheit geben kann
dass man die nicht mehr in die
freiheitsrechte massiv einschreiten muss
eingreifen muss warum dann nicht jetzt
mich ich kann weil dienstag ich finde
ich finde dafür wirklich gar keine
wirklichen worte wenn am mittwoch jetzt
die ministerpräsidenten zusammen kommen
sitzen sie da haben die bessere
erkenntnis gewonnen dass man jetzt
eigentlich die freiheit feiern kann und
sagen na ja wir machen das man
zwanzigster märz also in sechs wochen
warum nicht gleich also bitte bitte
bitte liebe politiker wenn ihr euch
jetzt an zusammenfindet und wenn ihr
endlich dem pfad der vernunft folgt dann
doch bitte gleich auch den zweiten
schritt machen und sagen wir machen das
so schnell wie möglich wir zielen auf
die nächste woche und ja der beste
vorschlag wäre eigentlich erst zum 22 22
zu machen dann bleibt uns nicht nur die
verdammte pandemie immer in erinnerung
sondern auch der freiheitstag wegen
dieses wunderbaren tat also klar von
bild live chef claus strunz ihrem studio
nachdem wir uns zunächst ein bisschen
gefreut haben natürlich über dieses
papier aber es hat er seine ecken und
kanten nach wie vor vor allen dingen die
masken pflicht da ist interessant was
alexander graf lambsdorff gestern aus
der bundesversammlung raus getwittert
hat der hat ein foto geschickt nämlich
dieses von der fdp fraktion die das
schön zusammensetzt und wir alle sehen
sofort ohne maske wunderbar so stellen
wir uns das alle vor wir wissen es gibt
eben ganz viele orte in denen genau das
nicht erlaubt es nämlich in den schulen
in vielen schulen zumindest in
deutschland und der fußballer der
nationalspieler ex nationalspieler
robert huth der hat genau das kritisiert
der sagt man kinder mit masken in die
schule schicken und dann das wort des
chips klaus also ja klar und das sieht
man wie viel druck und am kessel ist und
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
politik jetzt wirklich diesen druck
unter dem kessel noch sechs wochen
halten will ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht vorstellen dass ich jetzt
dann noch jemand an die regeln hält also
das ist ja quasi der sinn entzogen es
ist dies ist die grundlage weg und dann
muss man ja gleich sagen und daraus
folgt deshalb freiheit für alle wieder
aber nein wir sagen die grundlage ist
weg die überzeugung ist da das ist für
uns aber wir brauchen noch die zeit
damit unser bürokratie apparates
bewältigen kann weil und jetzt kommen
solltet euch fest also die nächste
bundestags versammlung sitzungswoche wie
das heißt hier in der hauptstadt ist
nach in dieser woche am 14 märz und ich
ahne doch dass der zwanzigste märz von
dem 14 märz abhängt das bedeutet weil
die damen und herren
bundestagsabgeordneten erst in vier
wochen wieder zeit haben nach berlin zu
kommen vorher ist ja noch fasching und
da müssen sie noch dieses und jenes
machen erst weil sie dann wieder zeit
finden sich mit dieser frage die so ins
geschäft und ins privatleben fast aller
menschen in deutschland ein greift zu
befassen deshalb müssen wir den 20 märz
abwarten und meine erwartungshaltung
wäre eigentlich dass sie am mittwoch in
der mpk sagen das ist jetzt unser plan
für die freiheit und das noch in dieser
woche der sitzungswoche des bundestages
die grundlagen dafür geschaffen werden
und dann glaube ich kann es sogar zu
einer neuen gemeinsamkeit zwischen
regierenden und regierten kommen in der
frühlingssonne gemeinsam frei und auch
wieder mehr zu gemeinsinn in ganz
deutschland zur überwindung der unruhen
sd eine skepsis dieter grad anklang bei
den bei den bürgerinnen bürgern mit dem
gerät ja ich habe auch noch so eine
andere skepsis was ist eigentlich wenn
am
17 märz
karl lauterbach eine studie aus england
hervorzieht dieser habe das alles wird
noch schlimmer wackelt dann der
zwanzigste wieder gehen wir dann wieder
in diese spirale rein also wenn doch
jetzt klar ist wie es sein soll dann
jetzt machen also dass hier keine
studien mehr gelesen werden durch karl
lauterbach steht noch nicht drin in
dieser beschlussvorlage dass wir hier
mit das lesen es ist verboten danke
klaus mit seinen versuchen deine meinung
hierbei bild live also das ist das
papier das sie heute kennen müssen sie
erfahren alles bei bild live über dieses
wichtige papier zum corona gipfel am
mittwoch alle maßnahmen sollen fallen
alle tief greifenden maßnahmen und zwar
erst am 20 märz